[Music]
ad was finally revealed during the
Pretty Little Liars series finale but
the signs were there all along
even when the cast tried to throw us off
I think a girl could read could have
planned all of it my co-host Judy
Crossman I'd this is our series that
Spencer has a twin and that she's the
one that's been tormenting everyone I'm
just going to put that out I'm just
going to put that other yeah I mean okay
I don't know what to say to that
literally everybody could have a twin
and it would make sense on the show it
looks like married dream is savvy
Spencer are we meant to believe the
fattest Spencer because there's rumors
out there that she has a twin and that
is what our urinary and I talk argue
about that about us that's Spencer you
think it's possible that Spencer has
explained that that airport scene
looking back on it a second time I think
that it could be possible I can't she
had a bearing with with Wren because she
looked different she was tired babe I
feel like with Spencer is going to be a
race is going to be a resolution to her
character but she's got a lot more drama
to go through before that happens I
think everyone's always wanted to with
the twin theory because of the books
what if she has a twin twins lasing
running her family I don't know you know
it's interesting too that you have Jason
do learn to like be like Jesus Jason
heard about the twin theories out there
I want to get this right these fans like
really get into it
so they dig up so many things I'm just
like wait what but whoa
I mean that's actually very interesting
theory I think it would be really
interesting I've always been saying that
like Spencer's a I would love it so much
it would have to be some serious like I
don't know like Fight Club like Tyler
Durden